well there's been another mass shooting
this one at a school this one the
deadliest school shooting since sandy
hook elementary school shooting in 2012.
and um
guys this is this is not normal uh
yesterday i did a story about how we've
had 210 mass shootings so far in 2022
and while i was doing that segment i
noticed that a 211th shooting had been
added from monday so yesterday tuesday
morning i recorded that segment and in
the time from when i gathered the data
to when i recorded the segment
a monday shooting had been added to the
list so while i was talking we went from
210 to 211 mass shootings
before that segment published yesterday
a 212th mass shooting this year took
place
another teen gunman at an elementary
school in uvalde texas
killed his grandmother before going to
school
as of right now 19 dead the shooter also
dead the shooter bought the guns legally
when he turned 18. in other words the
law worked to the extent that this was
someone that
got the guns legally and then
we had this shooting
now of course
it's hard to know all the details so
soon after the event the details so far
are horrifying for example one new
detail is all of the deaths happened in
one classroom in the school
imagine the carnage that we're talking
about here even for the kids that
survived
unspeakable
as always
mental illness is being brought up by
the right as the sole factor and cause
here and it's like a broken record but
as i've said before
the mental illness element is not an
either or after the buffalo shooting and
now as well we're hearing the right that
doesn't want to talk about guns and
availability of guns talk only about
mental illness
it's not an either or
often there's a mental illness component
and if that's what we believe we should
make mental health treatment
more accessible more affordable easier
to get
just about every republican is against
that they will say when we try to expand
access to all health care including
mental health coverage these republicans
who say the mass shootings which are an
epidemic are merely a mental illness
problem they say no weak but what you
want to do is a government takeover of
health care what you want to do is
socialism so the first thing is if they
really
want to deal with this as a mental
health issue why do they vote against
every opportunity to expand access and
reduce cost to mental health care number
two we have to say
most mentally ill people are not violent
and never commit any violent acts or
crimes so sometimes there's the reaction
from some in my audience to say even
mentioning mental illness is an insult
to the mentally ill
well it's not about being an insult it's
just that
almost never do mentally ill people
commit crimes or become violent now
for the small percentage that does
if there are fewer guns around if it's
more difficult to get guns in general
whatever violence mentally ill people
try to commit will be less lethal
if
the mentally ill people who would kill
20 with assault rifles can only get a
handgun maybe they only kill five if
they can't even get the handgun
maybe they can only kill one with a
knife or you get the point okay so even
if we concede there's a mental illness
component well we should fund dealing
with it and it would still be better if
those few mentally ill people who want
to commit violence have a harder time
getting guns
at the end of the day this is an issue
of more than one thing number one
too much and too easy access to guns
that's one piece
number two we have a cultural problem in
the united states in the united states
i don't want to say it's necessarily
celebrated although in some places it is
it's
looked at as plausibly okay by too many
people in the united states
that it's okay to use firearms to solve
interpersonal or societal problems
can't find a girl
well maybe use a gun to go and do
something
disaffected by society having a conflict
at work the disgruntled employee
shootings like we saw on public transit
in california what was it a year ago six
months ago 18 months ago i don't even
remember so that is another component
there's a there's a real cultural issue
in the united states and number three
there is the element of untreated and
undiagnosed mental illness as a result
of the disastrous health care system
that republicans refuse to fix
the same people who are saying the only
problem is mental health are the ones
who consistently vote not to expand
access to mental health treatment
there's mental health issues everywhere
it's important to know in the united
states there's way more guns and way
more easy access to guns and that's a
unique issue in the united states we
also have issues with access and costs
when it comes to mental health treatment
so there's there's violent video games
everywhere
there's mental health issues everywhere
so when a republican or anybody else
says this is just about mental illness
ask what legislation they supported to
fund mental health treatment to make it
affordable to make it accessible
one other thing on this
you also have to understand
the absurdity of republican arguments
about how limiting access to guns would
achieve nothing for years republicans
have been saying
if you explain to kids
how to have safe sex and you give them
access to condoms and birth control
pills
they're going to have more sex
and they won't take the birth control
pills correctly or whatever and it's
going to be more unwanted pregnancy if
you if you do that you're going to get
more unwanted pregnancy
they've said for years if you have these
harm reduction safe drug use sites
it's going to encourage more drug use
and it's going to lead to more overdose
but then they want to say more access to
guns has no impact on gun violence that
doesn't really make any sense but
meanwhile they say if you ban abortion
you'll end abortion well if that's true
why wouldn't limiting access to guns at
least to reduce mass shootings oh no no
no that's different nothing will work to
stop this
say people in the only country where
this regularly happens well that doesn't
make sense we've really tried nothing
but we're out of ideas the only thing we
have is arming teachers which we're
going to get to in a moment
aren't we at the point where it's worth
trying some gun safety regulations along
with other things just to see if it's
work do what many other countries have
done with great success
and see if it works here i mean parents
had to provide
dna samples because their kids bodies
were mutilated beyond recognition to try
to figure out who are these dead kids we
can't even talk about gun safety
regulations and now they're go they're
back on the arm teachers train which i
want to talk about next
so um i hate to break it to many of the
people in the audience who think that
just more guns and more places will make
everybody safer
but there was at least one armed officer
at the school in uvalde texas yesterday
where this horrible mass shooting took
place there was at least one armed
officer there who was unable to stop the
incident okay so what republicans are
now going to is no no this isn't about
guns or gun safety or whatever we need
more guns in school so that the teachers
and the administrators and the janitors
and the whoever can protect the kids
let's go to some examples from yesterday
this is the immediate aftermath of the
shooting in uvalde texas asked on
newsmax how he would deal with the
school shooting problem in texas the
texas attorney general ken paxton said
well let's arm the teachers as as you
well know the state of texas not a
stranger to shootings that either begin
in schools or wander in schools
i know your team has dealt with this
before what were some of the solutions
and i know that governor abbott and
lieutenant governor patrick have also
come up with tasks for task forces to
harden these task forces and oh yeah
yeah guys what about the guns schools so
they're not easy targets easy prey for
crazy people who go nuts with firearms
uh
what what can you tell us has been
remember crazy people who go nuts with
firearms well i'd rather have crazy
people who go nuts with a knife than
with assault rifles that's just me
talked about in the past what has been
implemented and what hasn't been
yeah sadly this has happened again and
it's a horrible tragedy but the types of
things that we talked about and i'll
never forget it after the santa fe
shooting it was having one point of
entry making it more difficult for
people even to get in that point of
entry make sure that they
and having potentially teachers and
other administrators who have gone
through training who are armed because
teachers and administrators who have
gone through training and who are armed
they're all on this bandwagon texas
lieutenant governor dan patrick went on
tucker carlson's show last night and
said let's harden the targets we can do
a lot of things and texas has done a lot
of things after the santa fe shooting
obviously we have to do more we have to
harden these targets so no one can get
in ever except through one entrance
maybe that would would help maybe that
would stop someone but it's really
bigger than that tucker it's we're a
core society we're we're a society
that's just at each other's throats all
the time and and and we're better than
we're better than this as a nation we
have to harden targets schools now they
have to be hardened and at least dan
patrick is getting at the fact that
there is a cultural component here
although he would say it's just
political disagreement if the liberals
would just let us ban abortion and put
guns everywhere and make taxes on the
rich zero at least if well
actually part of the problem is the gun
culture of the united states uh radical
republican texas senator ted cruz said
oh yeah you've got to just arm the
teachers and uh rather you've got you've
got to have more armed cops there we
know from past experience that the most
effective tool for keeping kids safe
uh is armed law enforcement on the
campus you know inevitably when there's
a murder of this kind
you see politicians try to try to
politicize it you see democrats and a
lot of folks in the media whose
immediate solution is to try to
restrict
the constitutional rights of law-abiding
citizens that doesn't work yeah um and
then lastly a news max host named um i
believe this is grant stinkfield
he says uh you've got to have armed good
guys at the schools that's the only way
well folks by now you have heard about
this animal that went into rob
elementary school this morning in the
tiny call it a border town called uvalde
texas
this animal murdered 18 elementary
school kids and three adults now numbers
keep rising my heart aches for the loved
ones of all of the victims as i watched
the media today play out its
wall-to-wall coverage of the shooting
they only seem to talk about guns
deranged violent individuals and how we
keep guns out of their hands if you want
to save lives you can talk about that
it's important but the number one issue
that needs to be discussed is how do you
stop a gunman the moment he comes
calling
the answer is secure our schools it's
still not happening and in my opinion
institute programs where school faculty
can carry in school after going through
in-depth training on a voluntary basis
yeah so listen um there are reports that
two uvaldi police officers and a school
resource officer
fired at the shooter but weren't able to
stop him from entering the building
that's one report
we're still working on confirming that
but at minimum according to eric estrada
from the texas department of public
safety
there was at least the school district
police officer who worked at the school
and saw the shooter
with a rifle
with body armor engaged the suspect and
was unable to stop him so quite
literally there were supposed good guys
with guns there and they still didn't
stop him now their reaction instead of
saying well maybe the problem is how
easily the the kid got guns
they say we just didn't have enough
good guys with guns at the school you
essentially need an army there they will
not stop until
it is
they would rather turn schools almost
into like forward operating bases
reminiscent of the military rather than
restrict access to guns and um by the
way
the people now they're saying let's give
the guns to the teachers
these are the same teachers that for the
last two years they've been saying these
are the indoctrinators these are the
critical race theory teaching
irresponsible indoctrinators who are
grooming our kids
those are the people that now they want
to give the guns to it's whatever will
justify keeping as many guns as possible
around that's the bottom line the rest
of the world looks at us like we're
insane
and at some point you have to wonder are
we insane
um
when you look at
correlation isn't necessarily causation
but look at this correlation between
guns and mass shootings from the new
york times the u.s has the most guns and
the most shootings no one else is even
close in guns no one else is even close
in shootings now i concede we have a
problem here with gun culture but the
same people that want to keep the guns
around like that culture so they're not
going to solve that there is sometimes a
mental illness component but the people
saying that's the problem don't want to
fund treatment for mental health but
might it not be worth seeing what
happens if we limit the number of guns
that are out there and i hate to be so
negative and cynical
but if nothing was done after 26 kids
were killed in sandy hook in 2012
is something ever going to be done about
this i don't know
i don't know
um let me know your thoughts
one more thing i want to briefly touch
on related to the uvaldi school shooting
we now are very familiar in the united
states with this circle where nothing
happens okay and i know that i'm
sounding negative and cynical but this
is typically the way that it goes
you can start the circle anywhere i'll
start with the mass shooting mass
shooting happens okay
explosive media coverage for several
days a week a couple of weeks tragedy
uh something must be done but not too
much because people need their gun
rights and you got to stop bad guys with
guns with good guys with guns and okay
we don't want to do too much but
something must be done it's a tragedy
okay well since you can't
really get anything done because oh we
can't restrict we can't do that we end
with thoughts and prayers and there's
vigils and all of these different things
okay and then a little bit of time
passes and the more guns in more places
people get really defensive about doing
anything to make it harder to get guns
and to reduce the supply of guns
floating around so you get gridlock and
nobody ends up doing anything and then
people forget about the last major
shooting now in this case you know when
we say we're back to normal
the last mass shooting was like the last
major
nationally significant mass shooting
because there were a bunch in between
was buffalo 11 days ago so back to
normal now means it's been like a week
since the last major mass shooting but
we're quote back to normal
and nothing gets done and then there's
another mass shooting and the cycle
starts all over again except it's just
happening more quickly because like i
said the last one was 11 days ago we
weren't even really back to normal it's
just now normal
that there's been a mass shooting a few
days ago
that's the cycle and unless you break
that cycle sadly nothing's going to
change let me know your thoughts find me
on twitter at d pacman
forget that the best way to support the
david pakman show is by becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials you also get access to
our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
it just so happens that later this week
just a couple of days after the uvalde
texas school shooting the most deadly
school shooting since sandy hook in
2012. that happened in texas and later
this week the national rifle association
the largest and most most powerful
gun rights lobby what they mean is gun
manufacturer lobby they work from the
gun manufacturers to sell as many guns
as possible the nra is having its
convention in houston texas the shooting
happened in texas the nra is having its
convention in texas and who is scheduled
to attend that convention well donald
trump is scheduled to speak there and
ted cruz is scheduled to speak there
republican texas senator and greg abbott
is scheduled to speak there the
republican texas governor
just days after the uvalde mass shooting
these three republicans who advocate for
more guns in more places and say guns
aren't the problem and we need more guns
they're going to show up and speak
presumably in praise
of the national rifle association which
has been one of the most important
corporate organizations that's what they
are
at putting more guns in more places
making guns easier to access easier to
buy and allowed
uh in more places in american society
how do they do it
what will they say how do they justify
their presence there how do you justify
the existence of the nra in this context
this is a celebration of guns this is a
place that celebrates
making it easy for people to obtain
firearms and just about any type of
firearm that they would want
uh by the way guns will not be allowed
at donald trump's speech they may also
not be allowed at greg abbott's speech
now um
the
of they always like to say well that's
secret services
decision okay well needless to say
if guns make everybody super safe
then why is it a danger to anyone even
if it's secret service saying we don't
allow guns around the president
if this is an organization premised on
the notion that more guns make people
safe you would think the safest that the
president would be
would be around a room full of people
with guns because if any crazy bad guy
with a gun thought to do anything there
would be so many good guys with guns
there to stop him
uh
bizarre all absolutely bizarre
it's very strange also by the way
that when these events happen all of a
sudden the nra also goes to
our thoughts and prayers and all these
different things they're certainly not
going to bring up their role in making
firearms easier to access and the cycle
with the nra is as follows and as i've
said before
the nra uh wins
whether there are lots of shootings or
whether there are not and here's the way
it works
it's actually genius in a way
if there's no mass shootings for a while
which i mean it's like this is the
united states there's always mass
shootings but let's i'll i'll pr i'll
kind of qualify that by saying if
there's no mass shooting that gets
national news for a week because there's
mass shootings basically every day in
the united states but if we go a while
without one of these
major quote major mass shootings like
buffalo sandy hook or more recently in
uvalde the gun rights people will say
it's thanks to guns
the reason that we are not having that
many mass shootings and what means that
many by the way it's a sixth standard
but they'll say people are not going out
and doing mass shootings because they
know
others might be armed the shooters don't
want to go out there and have their
plans foiled by a good guy with a gun
now at the same time they want to say
that the shooters are all simply
mentally ill
if they are simply mentally ill they're
probably not rationally thinking well
i shouldn't go and do a shooting because
there might be a good guy with a gun
mentally ill people if you believe their
story wouldn't be thinking that way but
regardless if you have fewer mass
shootings they say it's thanks to guns
if you start to see more mass shootings
right
they say this is a reminder
this is evidence
that everybody's got to be armed because
it's so dangerous out there we need more
firearms and then of course the classic
is
if there's a mass shooting and there's a
democrat in the white house like joe
biden
the nra will announce
democrats and joe biden are coming for
your guns ted cruz is already saying it
others are already saying it they're
coming for your guns so you damn well
better get out there and buy some more
firearms and then the gun manufacturers
make massive profits the gun
manufacturers profit from mass shootings
there were record gun sales under obama
after sandy hook why well it's dangerous
out there there was a mass shooting so
you need guns to keep yourself safe and
barack obama is going to try to take
your guns away and then it is rinse
repeat rinse repeat time and time again
so are trump cruz and or abbott going to
bail on speaking at the nra convention i
don't know as of right now they're still
scheduled to speak what will they say
uh i can only imagine
we do have primary results from last
night the primary coverage was sort of
replaced in a great sense by this
horrible tragic mass shooting in uvalde
texas but there were primary results as
some of you know donald trump's new
obsession is his endorsement record now
i have to tell you it's all kind of
meaningless trump
mostly endorses people that are already
winning
or incumbents or obvious favorites and
so like your record when you're
endorsing mostly people that are
obviously going to win it doesn't really
mean that much but okay trump is
obsessed with his endorsement record
trump had some humiliating losses last
night i mean absolutely humiliating
losses in the georgia gubernatorial a
primary the republican primary in
georgia donald trump endorsed david
perdue the former republican senator
on the other hand mike pence endorsed
brian kemp the incumbent georgia
governor
it's not normal
for a president and a vice president so
recently out of office to be on the
opposite sides of races like this but
trump endorsed david perdue david perdue
was crushed by more than 50 points this
is one of the most humiliating losses in
recent political history among
well-known candidates okay sure often
you've got an incumbent against a
no-name and they win by 50. fine this is
a different situation this was actually
supposedly going to be a real race and
brian kemp defeated david perdue 74-22
a stunning victory for kemp and a
trouncing for donald trump
we then went to the georgia republican
secretary of state primary this is a
really important race this is who
controls the election in the state of
georgia brad raffensberger easily
defeating jody heiss trump endorsed jody
heiss brad raffensberger won by nearly
20 points now trump got himself some
wins without a doubt herschel walker won
and uh etc but two
major major losses for the failed former
president now some other important
results from yesterday stacey abrams won
in georgia this was a formality this was
uh she was unopposed in the democratic
gubernatorial primary stacey abrams will
now face brian kemp in november that's a
really important election
and when we talk about
what are some of the most important
elections there are so many in november
but we've talked about how pennsylvania
senate could ultimately decide uh who
controls the senate in the next uh
congress that's going to be important
there's lots of really important racist
florida governor ron desantis running
there that could set the tone for 2024.
abrams versus kemp in georgia is a big
big deal now also from georgia in the
14th district yes marjorie taylor green
easily won her primary there was every
expectation that she would she had
roughly 70 of the vote marcus flowers
easily won on the democratic side so
they will face each other that's a
really great race to get involved in in
the sense that defeating marjorie taylor
green in particular after the defeat of
madison cawthorne it would be amazing
but as far as a general election
george's 14th district is very red
and it's going to be an uphill battle
and then lastly in the arkansas
republican gubernatorial primary as
expected sarah huckabee sanders easily
won she's donald trump's former white
house press secretary she will likely
win the governorship chris jones won the
democratic primary for governor and in
november it will be chris jones against
sarah huckabee sanders a very red state
it is you know speaking speaking
honestly with you it's difficult to
imagine that there would be a real
opportunity for chris jones there but
potentially another race to follow so
some humiliations for donald trump last
night when he posted um he posted today
to his platform truth social truth
essential yeah he barely spoke about the
ones that he lost focusing only on the
win so not not a major surprise um next
week more uh primaries which we will be
covering and all of these stories will
have more coverage on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show today i'm going to be
speaking with daniel levitan who's a
psychologist neuroscientist author and
professor emeritus at mcgill university
some of his books include a field guide
to lies critical thinking with
statistics and the scientific method and
also weaponized lies how to think
critically in the post-truth era it's
really great having you on i appreciate
it
thank you for having me david so i mean
where to start where to start uh you
know i i think maybe one place that
would be interesting would be for
context you know we we've recently been
doing a lot of thinking about
how to best engage in conversations with
people who might have different opinions
but also importantly
who maybe don't have a factual
foundation or basis on which we can have
those conversations or people who can't
tell the difference between news
reporting
and conspiracy articles that might be
shared on facebook as just general
examples
one approach
is to
speak to these folks with like a
socratic type method of questioning
gently probing
how did you come to this conclusion how
do you determine if a news source is
trustworthy it's a it's a very long
process admittedly which sometimes is
effective at changing minds and
sometimes is not where maybe we would
start with you is can you talk a little
bit about whether you believe that
that's an ideal framework for some of
these conversations or whether there
might be better or at least different
approaches to pair with that
i agree with you that we've got a
problem and the reason that
we are so divided as a country is we're
not using the same facts to come to
any any conclusion if at least we have
the same facts we may differ about how
we want to proceed from there
but without that it's bedlam
and uh i'm inspired here by the work of
lee mcintyre a philosopher who's done a
lot of work on this and i i'm with you
and with lee
uh
you can't
reason somebody out of a position
they didn't reason themselves into in
the first place
all you can do is listen uh
understand
and make under try to understand where
they're coming from
uh
allow them not to feel judged by you
uh and then as you say
uh ask questions about how they came to
believe what they believed and whether
they think uh you know step by step
is this a reliable source is there
another way to look at it
and as as uh
as mcintyre says and as you said it's a
very long and arduous process but
it's all we got for now there's no
shortcuts in in other words we've
interviewed lee by the way on the
program and it was it was fascinating
in your work overall over the years
you've gone to the micro level of how
graphs are used to deceive and to lie
and you've also talked much more macro
sort of the way that that we just
started
today for 2022 where it's rapid fire
social media sharing of fake articles
and it's truncated y-axis when you look
at an unemployment rate or stock market
numbers i mean it's sort of like an
all-of-the-above thing can we go a
little narrower and specific about what
you see as some of the most commonly
used tools of deception
yes thank you uh
and we are currently doing some research
on this
and there may be some quicker ways to
move the needle a little bit that we can
get to later
distorting graphs uh is a big thing as
you mentioned a truncated y-axis where
you know the y-axis is the up and down
one and it looks like you've got a
really big difference
but they've zoomed in on a difference
that isn't really a difference to
distort it
people can say all kinds of things with
graphs if they didn't label the axes if
they're not labeled with numbers or what
the
quantities are
you don't know anything
and my approach has been to educate i'm
an educator to to try and educate people
about the different tricks and swindles
and really i think the most effective
thing to do is to start
with 12-year-olds
i don't know that we're going to reach
people my age who have already made up
their minds maybe not even people your
age unless they're especially
open-minded
but if we start with 12 year olds in
another 10 years we'll have solved the
problem
yeah and you know what when one says
that there's a particular group that
says you're talking about
indoctrination when really you're
talking about the opposite you're
talking about a toolbox for people to
think for themselves rather than be
indoctrinated into any particular
worldview is that correct
that's perfect i've never
sought to tell somebody what to think
just to teach them how to take a problem
apart and how to think about it and form
their own conclusions and if they come
up with a different conclusion than i do
that's that's what democracy is all
about
i like you i embraced that discussion as
long as the process was reasonable
and and somebody wasn't tricking them
when it comes a little more specifically
to news consumption which you know we
can include radio television and online
kind of all platforms i'm going to use
an analogy to what many of us do when we
look at an article or hear a piece of
news for the first time one of the
difficulties it seems in self-driving
vehicles is that there are some
decisions that we as humans make
intuitively and quickly
that are really hard to have a computer
mirror a classic is do you go through
the yellow light or do you stop
and we're at the same time calculating
how fast are we going someone behind us
the width of the intersection all of
these different things and we're making
these decisions very very quickly in the
same way many of us myself included
similarly make decisions when we are
first presented with a news article that
we see somewhere
that's
fine i think to intuitively kind of have
that perception but there really is
a probably better sequence or toolbox
that we can have
to be able to assess for ourselves is a
piece of news or article trustworthy are
the assertions accurate what would such
a toolbox look like what would such a
process be for the average news consumer
well to begin with i think we
can
can recognize although we don't all
agree on this that there are some people
who are experts in certain topics
so if you want to know about climate
change talk to somebody who works in the
field somebody who is a climate change
scientist
don't talk to a
geneticist
or a biologist
a lot of the climate change
misinformation has come from people who
are not expert and for that matter if
you want to know about
something going on in the brain
don't talk to your foot doctor i mean he
or she might know but it's less likely
so
i think the average person doesn't uh
whoever that average person is don't
appreciate that there really are experts
who know things
virologists
is are an interesting case because we've
during the pandemic
seen a lot of flip-flopping
and so people say oh well they don't
know anything or they're they're
they're just trying to make money off of
us and the reality is
the second part of this is to help
people understand how science works
because a lot of the information we
consume is scientific
science is a self-correcting process
they're flip-flopping
as they should
when new information comes in
they update their views
the third thing we can do i think is
understand that there's a hierarchy of
information sources none is perfect
none is unbiased all are biased and
imperfect
but what you want in an information
source is one that will
like science self-correct print a
retraction if it's wrong check its
sources before it goes with the
the article so tmz is a sort of favorite
case of mine because they did break the
story of michael jackson's death before
anyone else
but they got lucky
for every story they broke that was
right they wrote 20 stories that were
not right they've said that miley cyrus
was dead all kinds of stuff
and
so i tend to trust sources that are a
little bit more deliberate and
circumspect
and everybody has to draw the line
somewhere different but i think we all
agree there are sources that
are just kind of capricious they say
what they want and included in those
unfortunately
are um
i guess they're not really
news shows they're commentary shows
people commenting on the news
which is not the news
right and that goes to media literacy in
in a sense i mean it's being able to
distinguish the difference between news
and opinions sometimes i'll get emails
praising me for being unbiased and i'll
say
i love that you love my show but i am
not a news show whose bias we really
should evaluate in those terms i mean
this is a program about my opinion the
problem is that there are media actors
that are deliberately blurring that line
oh for sure it leads to better ratings
if they say this is what's really going
on and let me tell you what they don't
want you to know
and i have unique access to facts that
you will never encounter
that always makes me a little suspicious
there's the you mentioned climate change
and a couple of other things which i
think lend themselves to to this next
sort of idea there's a contingent that
has
uh sort of um uh placed itself seemingly
above
the fray in terms of some of these
partisan disagreements by taking the
position that they are and this is my
it's sort of a pejorative an enlightened
centrist in a sense they've determined
here's what one side thinks and here's
what the other side thinks and i can
rise above this
and find the truth and it happens to be
sort of somewhere in the middle so if
you watch fox news you watch msnbc and
the truth is between those two and of
course the problem with this is with
something like climate science you know
if you say well let's bring in one
person who says it's real and one person
who says it's not and the truth is it's
sort of like in the middle this seems
like a like a problem this idea of the
truth being in the middle doesn't it
i agree there's not too look there are
two sides to many stories
uh but there are not two sides to a
story if one side is a lie
or a complete you know fabrication or a
distortion that that's not a side
and now that raises this thorny issue
well of who's going to decide
what's a lie and what's not and that
gets back to where we started i think
each of us needs to be armed
to make that decision for ourselves we
need a toolkit and i've you know i've
i've written a couple of books that
provide the toolkit but lots of people
have i'm not here to hawk my books there
are a lot of books on critical thinking
uh and
it's a muscle that you have to exercise
you don't learn it once
and then keep it because as you say it
goes against our evolutionary
bias which is to make snap decisions
rather than deliberate ones what my
teacher danny kahneman wrote about in
his book
thinking fast and slow
and so this enlightened centrist
you know one of them uh you may know of
is called allsides.com
yeah
where he presents four different views a
left to right
you know moderate left moderate right
and an extreme left and extreme right
and then you can decide
um
the issue i have and i told him uh john
gable is that some of the stuff on both
sides is really not fact-based so it's
not helpful
um and they need to do a better job of
sorting that out and again i come back
to well
as a rule of thumb
i would ask some experts and if the
experts disagree that's fine
i would report that but there are some
things that experts
really don't disagree about they
the suitable experts will tell you
that the measles vaccine does not cause
autism right the information that was
based on was retracted
the guy was found to have fabricated
data
andrew wakefield he was his medical
license was taken away i mean that's
about as strong
a case as we have and yet people still
believe it because there are two sides
they think
you mentioned daniel kahneman who wrote
thinking fast and slow uh and much of
much of the book is based on the work he
did with with amos versky um one of the
things that daniel kahneman writes about
is that so much of our everyday lives is
based on certain cognitive biases and
heuristics that we many of us unless you
really take some time to learn about
them you don't understand them you know
availability bias you're very much
skewed to kind of what you see around
you as one example um
sometimes it's it's a bias to loss
aversion even when a loss and a gain can
sort of be the same thing mathematically
but depending on how it's presented it
feels different
which of those biases and heuristics do
you think are most relevant when it
comes to news consumption and what we
believe or disbelieve or how we evaluate
news
you know i i worked in conomon's lab as
a student and worked on some of the
experiments and uh kahneman
i'm sorry i worked in taversky's lab and
condiment was around a lot and
trevorski and kahneman both said
that
this stuff is so hard you can teach it
to somebody and then they fall
again a month later and even phds and
statistics were failing
our little tests
fiendishly difficult
um
i think we have to face
the fact that we are all biased as you
have admirably done
we're biased towards i mean in a
trivial non-news way some people are
biased towards wanting to live in cities
some people like to live in the country
or in suburbs some people
want to take a vacation to the beach
some in the mountains those are biases
or preferences but
hard to distinguish
when it comes to
what we can arm ourselves with
yeah
tversky and kahneman have this inventory
of like 50 different things
availability uh heuristic
representativeness heuristic the uh
belief perseverance
all these things
i don't know that we need to learn those
that's a lot of work yeah
um
i mean i find it entertaining too and i
would encourage anybody who wants to to
do so because it sharpens your mind
immeasurably
but from day to day
uh i don't you i don't stop and think
about that stuff unless it pokes me in
the face
it's such an obvious example of that
bias
either in reporting or in my own muddled
thinking about something
what i really use is i look at the
headline and i ask myself if it's even
plausible
does it does it just pass
a simple plausibility test uh and then i
look at who's saying it and where they
got the information and that that sorts
through about eighty percent of it for
me
yeah and and it's admittedly a very
strange time because i think five years
ago
a headline like
the former president was flushing
documents down a toilet we would all say
it's not plausible and and that would be
the end but things do change right i
mean to some degree we have to adjust to
the current circumstances
well that's a that's a wonderful point
there's this arcane thing we call
bayesian inferencing right which is just
a fancy name that statisticians and
doctors
and lawyers and judges use for
if new information comes in you put it
on the scale
so uh you know maybe the evidence for
climate change was that it was
um
just a natural occurrence maybe people
thought that 40 years ago and then
information comes in and at some point
the scales might be evenly balanced or
slightly tipped and the idea is
you have to stay open-minded you have to
be willing to learn something new that
may shake the very core of what you
believe
uh is there a single question that you
could leave us with that is the most
effective at starting conversations with
people in order to get them to have an
open mind
um
some some version of uh oh
i didn't know that or i didn't realize
that
where did you learn that or how did you
learn that right
and then just follow
follow the question
and see where it goes and again
don't try to shame somebody uh
that doesn't work
don't try to
say that their view is ridiculous right
because they're going to shut down
emotionally and become defensive and
we've seen the research they'll double
down
but in our lab and in gordon pennycook's
lab in canada a simple question of
uh do you think that's reliable
or where did you learn that or you know
a lot of people say unreliable things it
could
i don't know tell me could this be one
of them
yeah another one that i think is
interesting is what would it mean for
your world view
if this wasn't true
and you know with the trump was actually
the winner stuff there's a lot
emotionally wrapped up in the belief
that joe biden didn't really win and not
not everybody's willing to answer the
question but for a lot of these folks it
would be really
uh impactful
if their guide just genuinely lost
rather than there was this major
multi-state conspiracy to steal it and
but but not everybody's necessarily open
to taking that question seriously
well it's difficult david because in in
one version of this story what you have
to realize is oh a whole bunch of people
have been lying to me right and i bought
it am i that vulnerable and that
gullible right and
am i that defenseless uh
what we see with older adults who get
scammed
by con artists is they don't want to
tell anybody because they're embarrassed
right and they kind of don't want to
admit that it was their fault for not
asking the right questions they'll just
say oh well this person lied to me and i
you know
it's true some of those scammers are
very very good liars but uh in
government and media we have some very
very good liars too that's true that's
true we've been speaking with daniel
levitan whose books include a field
guide to lies critical thinking with
statistics in the scientific method and
also weaponized lies how to think
critically in the post-truth era so
appreciate your time today thank you
thank you david this is fun
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right this is super interesting
yesterday on the program the view there
was a confrontation between two former
trump staffers the very well-known
kellyanne conway and the slightly less
well-known alissa farah griffin they
both previously worked for trump at
different points in time this is a
complete train wreck of a conversation
where they start going at each other
let's just let's just jump into it and
uh then we'll discuss because it is
fascinating do you want to acknowledge
something you said last segment um i
remember flying on air force one in
october of 2020 and two very senior
advisors to the president dave bossie
and corey lewandowski turned to me and
said we would be winning this race if it
was kellyanne running the campaign so i
think that there's there's some real
truth to the direction it went the
second time around and that perhaps you
having a more senior role would have
changed that um but i have to ask you
something we served together um briefly
in the white house my second time uh i
admired you the first time when i was
working for pence you were very helpful
what happened the second time oh the
second time no i just met i looked up to
you i wasn't you're in more comparable
roles i was a more junior role the first
time um i broke with the president ahead
of january 6 when the big lie started
being shared i resigned in december
december 4th and i spoke out after
january 6 when i saw a violent mob
assault the capital question in here yes
okay um
how how do you is there a question in
here so it starts to get testy and
kellyanne clearly doesn't like the
direction this is going still defend him
do you still think he could be a good
president after he tried to overturn our
democracy okay so i left three months
before you did for my children i have
four of them and i i said less drama
more mama and that's exactly what i did
i think you stayed a whole month after
the election that you were having a
problem with but that's i wanted to help
my junior staff get jobs
i think people should know that because
i haven't seen you since you've changed
but i want to say this to you i didn't
change uh just to be clear i didn't
change i swore i don't know
you shouldn't hear every day
not to donald trump i know but alyssa i
know that you right as we all did
as we all did but um and i i appreciate
that i think there was a lot wrong with
the 2020 campaign and i think in
addition to that afterwards your former
boss mark meadows he was a terrible
chief of staff not matching the man did
not match the moment look at this this
is just everybody pointing the finger at
each other for what went wrong this this
is the rats abandoning the ship for a
global pandemic a re-election campaign
neither did you have trouble excuse me
protests after george george floyd's
murder he didn't match the moment at all
and didn't take advice but do you think
donald trump matched them and then he
allowed he allowed supplicant after
sycophant after showman to come before
the resolute desk and promise the
president that was the day they were
going to fly more votes in arizona
wisconsin pennsylvania
so this is fascinating because kellyanne
is basically saying it was mark meadows
fault that trump ended up believing all
this stuff about the big lie it wasn't
trump himself now of course personal
responsibility if trump
if if this story is true
isn't it trump's responsibility
ultimately to vet whether mark meadows
is really telling him the truth
i'll answer your question maybe you
missed it i was on abc live on january
6th
and i said people have to get out of the
capital what are you doing there why
have you reached the capitol what is
going on
alyssa if you're saying that
somehow you think
we're supposed to think that you've seen
the light and not just see your name in
lights that's not fair what do you mean
i'm still supporting you
you're not answering
i know but you're you're talking about
maybe a second term you've never
denounced donald trump that's when he
incited a violent mob that i did that
day first of all i didn't but then you
went
[Music]
go
a complete and total train wreck and
listen the there's a lot of uh uh kind
of posturing here in her new book
kellyanne conway levy's some
uh tell some
complicated stories about her
involvement and everybody now is
essentially trying to rewrite history in
the way that most advantages them uh but
what is very clear is that everybody's
pointing fingers at each other and just
a complete train wreck of a view episode
interesting to see okay real quick i
don't have a ton of time for this
particular story but i think it's an
important one to mention
we have a situation right now
where the republican party is blaming
biden for everything
but actively blocking solutions and this
might not really be a shock to you it's
like hey david yeah welcome to american
politics particularly republican
politics they're blaming joe biden for
the high gas prices
but just about every republican or every
republican voted against the crackdown
on gas price gouging they're blaming joe
biden for the baby formula shortage but
they voted against a deal uh that was a
bill that would actually deal with the
shortage and now they're saying put us
in power in november and it's terrifying
but they have a pretty good chance at
taking over so a couple of different
articles here to look at first of all
full list of 192 house republicans who
voted against the fda baby formula bill
okay the house last week
passed a 28 million emergency spending
bill to address the baby formula
shortage
it passed 231 to 192
mostly along party lines all house
democrats supported it
only 12 republicans did
and 192 republicans voted against it
hey here's a problem they claim to want
to solve it if you look at for example
elise stefanix she's a republican
congresswoman you look at her twitter
joe biden owns this baby formula crisis
she's posting pictures of babies she's
doing all these actually that might just
be a picture of her own birth
announcement yeah that is that has
nothing to do with baby formula but if
you scrub if you not directly anyway if
you scroll down her twitter you see gas
now at historic high energies uh biden's
energy crisis joe biden never should
have let the baby formula crisis reach
this point and then they vote against
the bill that would deal with it
you look at the gas prices there was a
bill passed by the house to deal with
gasoline price gouging it passed 217 to
207 with no republicans voting for it
and also four democrats voting against
it they complained that democrats do
nothing they blame biden for problems
democrats put together bills to actually
deal with some of these issues and they
vote against them and sometimes they'll
say well the bill wasn't perfect and of
course no bill is but this is not really
just a problem of republicans what
republicans are doing is unconscionable
but we have to also say
where is the democratic communications
arm it's like it's non-existent there's
no coherent messaging there's no
coherent marketing and pr strategy
republicans are active actively
sabotaging
baby formula gas prices all of these
problems that there's at least an idea
of how to not fix permanently but
improve upon
and republicans are getting in the way
of all of it and unfortunately democrats
are not coherently united with a
cohesive strategy to say look at what
they're doing
look at what they're doing one last
thing there's a lot of criticism of how
despite controlling the senate democrats
can't get a lot of stuff passed i think
it's important to understand that when
most things need 60 votes in the senate
if you have 50
you don't really control it sure you
control the agenda and if there's a tie
on something that you need 51 votes for
kamala harris can can make that 51st
vote but when you need 60 votes it's a
bit of a misnomer to say you control the
senate you can control the agenda uh and
i think that that's an important thing
to keep in mind we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p
here's a 17 year old kid who called in
who says
i've grown up being afraid of being shot
in school because of these mass
shootings let's listen to this
hi david it's august from uh wisconsin
and uh i'm just here to
talk about
the shooting
um
i'm 17 years old
and i had to grow up every day thinking
about what someone with a gun
would do
to me
and i'm incredibly outraged
at what all of you adults haven't done
right
and i think you're all cowards
for not having solved this problem
earlier
and soon i'll be able to vote
and you
have been for many years
and so uh let's do that
yeah
uh hard to even really follow that up so
i won't try to
we are going to talk about a bunch of
different things on the bonus show we
are going to talk about
a new policy on excessive force for
police officers we're going to talk
about a whole bunch of other things if
you're interested sign up at
joinpacman.com
and otherwise we'll be back with a new
show tomorrow